[Música]
ah
y
[Música]
seguramente con algo te conectas te
algo estás pensando
ese pensamiento que te está invadiendo
en este momento
lo elegís
o fue impuesto
estoy perdiendo estos segundos acá estoy
lo estoy invirtiendo
realmente yo no lo sé
no lo sé
una de las primeras imágenes que se me
vino mientras diseñaba esta charla fue
la del pensador de rodin
me puse a investigar me puse a leer
sobre el mismo y descubrí que fue creado
por allá por mil 880 para decorar la
puerta al museo de artes en parís y es
más tampoco se llamaba el pensador sino
que se llamaba el poeta
el segundo aspecto que se me vino a mi
mente fue pensar en la maravillosa mente
de víctor franco víctor frank fue una
persona que sobrevivió a los campos de
concentración un neurólogo un psiquiatra
y que en uno de sus tantos libros él
escribió algo como esto dice que al
hombre le pueden arrebatar todo salvo
una cosa la elección del pensamiento
personal
el tercer aspecto que se me vino a la
mente fue la imagen de pichón rivière o
pichón rivière fue una de las primeras
personas que introdujo a la argentina el
psicoanálisis y entre tantas frases
famosas él dijo algo como esto
somos lo que pensamos
ahora yo me pregunto y te pregunto a vos
también
realmente somos lo que pensamos
tenemos la elección del pensamiento
personal y esto que estamos haciendo hoy
va a terminar como nosotros queremos que
termine
pensalo piénsalo entre tanto que
pensamiento que el pensador que si soy
lo que pienso es como que me maria
lo voy a llamar al pensamiento turista
interior turista interior observo que
estamos en una sociedad que está un poco
estresada hay muchas personas que andan
desahuciadas desanimadas también no es
algo que estamos en una crisis
espectacular en una crisis espectacular
de estados de ánimo en una crisis de
falta de diálogo y en una superpoblación
de emoticones justos
quizás te quería sentar en la primera
fila en esta charla ted y me tocó hacia
atrás
'hemos y
tuve una diferencia con un amigo o con
un compañero de trabajo en moshi
tuve que dialogar con mi pareja quizás
en el tránsito y me pasa nuevamente esta
situación de moggi
mis hijos me piden más tiempo para que
pase con ellos
vuelve otra vez ciertos modos y
solamente me pasa a mí que me siento
identificado con esto o algunos de
ustedes también se ven identificados
es decir
esta crisis de estado de ánimo
es la que realmente define mi calidad de
vida
lo que yo creo es que
la calidad de vida está directamente
relacionada con la calidad y actitud de
mi turista interior y este turista
interior está directamente relacionado
con la calidad de preguntas que me hago
diariamente por ejemplo para que estás
hoy acá
qué quieres lograr cuál es tu sueño
para que se dice en esa relación tóxica
ya sea laboral o personal
cuantas cuantas sonrisas generas te soy
cuantas sonrisas genera estrés hoy
pregunta te lo pregunta te lo estamos
bastante bastantes apurados en esta
sociedad a mí me pasa que las horas
pasan demasiado rápido los días la
semana a los meses los años hace muy muy
muy muy rápido paremos un poco
observemos hacia nosotros mismos
escuchemos dialoguemos empezamos
empecemos a sentir realmente qué es lo
que nos sucede por el cuerpo le
preguntaron al conejo de alicia en el
país de las maravillas' a dónde vas tan
rápido no sé pero tengo mucha prisa
respondió
que no sabe dónde va ya llegó
el que no sabe dónde va ya llegó estamos
en la patagonia argentina y otro que
también va muy rápido son nuestros
vientos los vientos soplan muy fuerte y
no los podemos no podemos cambiar la
dirección del viento lo que sí podemos
hacer en base a nuestro turista interior
es orientar nuestra verdad orientar la
vela para ver cuál es el puerto al que
queremos llegar porque como me doy
cuenta de eso es gustavo como me doy
cuenta si estoy yendo bien o estoy
siendo mal porque en este viaje que
llamamos vida podemos transitar la
alejándonos del dolor o acercándonos al
placer
yo voy a decir como hago si estoy bien o
no
parando como dijimos un poco dialogando
conversando escuchando si las
intenciones de mi turista interior son
las mismas que yo tengo este seguro que
si son buenas si son buenas estas
intenciones a esto que llamamos vida lo
vamos a transitar un poquito un poquito
un poquito mejor
muchas veces personalmente me pasa que
yo quiero ir a que el puerto de allá
quiero arribar a aquel puerto y una
turista interior que está de paso o no
orienta la vela para otro lado yo quiero
orientar la brújula al norte y el
turista interior va para el este para el
oeste va para el sur - para donde yo
quiero y empiezo a tener una dicotomía
interna una lucha que me hace muy mal en
esos momentos yo me empiezo a decir a mí
mismo si puedo
si puedo es fácil y lo estoy haciendo
si puedo es fácil lo estoy haciendo y te
quiero invitar que lo digas conmigo si
puedo es fácil y lo estoy haciendo hay
que escuchar si puedo es fácil y lo
estoy haciendo
si puedo es fácil y lo estoy haciendo y
mira un compañero y decirle a alguien
que está al lado tuyo si puedo sí puedo
es fácil y lo estoy haciendo
si puedo es fácil y lo estoy haciendo
si puedo es fácil lo estoy haciendo y lo
repito una
y lo repito y lo repito una y otra vez
una y otra vez me lo repito a mí mismo
como un mantra porque se dice y la forma
más elevada de pensar es no pensar
y yo me lo empiezo a repetir una y otra
y otra y otra y otra vez y a quieto cayó
ese turista interior que está de paso o
no
y empiezo a generar una nueva creencia
este turista interior que está en mi
mente que es lo que realiza genera un
estado de ánimo genera una emoción esas
emociones que nosotros tenemos son las
que determinan nuestras acciones o
conductas que venimos haciendo en el día
a día y con estas conductas con estas
acciones que logramos resultados ya que
es donde se cierra este circuito mental
que todos los seres humanos tenemos
si el resultado es positivo fantástico
en esa área de tu vida que el resultado
es el que deseas buenísimo ahora qué
sucede si el resultado es negativo
qué pasa si esto que estás haciendo
realmente no lo deseas se dice que para
resultados diferentes que hay que hacer
cosas diferentes
totalmente cosas diferentes y una de
estas cosas diferentes que podemos
empezar a hacer es esta del mantra que
te compartí porque porque yo empiezo a
generar una nueva creencia y las
creencias son las que dominan los
turistas interiores y en base a esto yo
estoy como estoy
donde tenemos desde que nos levantamos
hasta este momento pasaron por nuestras
mentes más de diez mil turistas
interiores y cada uno de ellos orientó
la vela de forma diferente y quizás
quizás no te diste cuenta de eso
quizás no te diste cuenta de eso y así
se nos pasa la vida
si nos pasa la vida con situaciones
buenas o situaciones malas donde me
pongo el estadio de víctima donde todos
ustedes son los responsables de lo mal
que me va a mí y que todos me lo dicen a
mí esto me pasa a mí por culpa de otro o
salgo de ese estadio me pongo el traje y
la super capa de protagonista y me hago
cargo y responsable de que todo lo que
me sucede a mí es en base al turista
interior que yo hasta hoy elegí que ha
visto en mi mente me hago cargo soy
responsable problemas siempre vamos a
tener vamos a tener problemas sí dónde o
cuándo podemos hacer la diferencia
primero cuando sepa al puerto que yo
quiero llegar cuál es el puerto que
realmente quiero arribar segundo cuando
defina cuál es el turista interior que
yo quiero que realmente sea ese
oriente que lleve mi vela que sea el
capitán
de mi embarcación y tercero tercero es
cuando empezamos a descubrir esa cajita
dorada ese cofre que todos absolutamente
todos tenemos dentro y en este cofre en
esa caja tenemos
pasión tenemos determinación tenemos
constancia tenemos amor y todo aquello
que vos creas que no tenés todo todo
aquello que vos creas que no tenés está
ahí adentro como dije tenemos que saber
orientar nuestra vela
los mismos vientos soplan para todos
iguales y nunca nunca nunca nunca nunca
nunca vamos a poder cambiar la dirección
de los vientos los vientos son como son
no como nos gustaría que sean los
vientos son como son no como nos
gustaría que sean tiene eliges esta
crisis de estado de ánimo quién elige
estar enfermo
sin embargo hay algo que sí sí sí sí sí
sí sí sí sí sí podemos cambiar y que
depende pura exclusivamente de mí es la
elección del turista interior de este
pensamiento que yo quiero que habite en
mi mente para que para tener una mejor
calidad de vida para sacar la mejor
versión de mí mismo mi vida puede ser
una experiencia o una advertencia con el
transcurso del tiempo y que el tiempo va
pasando siempre siempre siempre vamos a
tener oportunidades o no
el transcurso del tiempo podemos llegar
a ser una persona vieja o una persona
sabia depende de este turista interior
que yo elija que habita en mi mente
pasa el tiempo
y podemos tener nuevas oportunidades
a partir de ahora
y el pensamiento vas a elegir
[Música]
ah
y